hey hey everybody out there thank you so
much for uh tuning in to
market takes this is my live stream i am
dion robon a markets reporter for the
wall street journal and again you were
watching market takes we are live
streaming right here on youtube uh
thanks for joining us and being with us
we are going to talk about everything
going on all things markets economy
data and and just everything that's
going on i'm going to talk through
what's coming out this week and what i
think investors money managers and just
folks who are interested and concerned
about what's happening in the economic
environment what's going on in the world
should be looking out for this week so
we're going to go through all that i'm
going to talk through the big reports
coming out this week we're going to talk
through what's going on in markets and
just really break down everything that i
think you ought to be looking out for in
the markets for the rest of this week
it's monday so we are getting started
right now on a rough patch we're going
to check in on the markets look at
stocks bonds oil gold kind of how
everything's moving in the markets and
right now it's a rough day a lot of red
out there on the markets as i look at it
wsj.com i'm seeing the s p 500 down a
little more than one percent
the nasdaq down about point two five
percent and the dow down about point
eight percent kind of straddling in
between those uh as we look out into the
oil markets we're seeing oil down about
five percent on wti uh and brent crude
down about 5.3 percent those numbers
though coming back a little bit from the
lows of where we were earlier uh in the
day the 10-year yield is about 2.79
percent that's down from where we
finished last week at 2.91
so bond yields coming down which means
price is going up which is good if
you're a bondholder
means that some of those worries maybe
are are coming back in and that folks
are getting a little more worried and
buying bonds those safe assets we're
also seeing a big increase in a spike in
the dollar as folks move out of those
other currencies uh currencies that
might be a bit more affected by
geopolitics uh the war in ukraine these
worries about china's covid19 slowdown
and moving into the kind of global safe
haven the u.s dollar
we're seeing that rising and again this
is a continuation of what we saw last
week we saw bond yields spiking higher
prices going down stock prices going
down
oil prices coming down um and and just
kind of a broad sell-off of everything
crypto you name it the price is down
today and we've seen that kind of
consistently coming from last week if we
remember last week the s p 500 was down
more than 2.7 almost 3 for the s p
nasdaq down almost 4 last week uh both
down for three straight weeks the dow
was down almost two percent but it was
actually petted for a weekly increase
until friday when it lost 2.82 its worst
day since june 11 2020.
so again we're seeing those consistent
rise the the two-year yield jumped 27
basis points last week the 10-year yield
rose 10 almost at 3 percent that's a
very important level because when yields
hit three percent uh that's really the
the number that a lot of economists and
asset managers pointed to and said okay
that's a level where folks start moving
out of stocks and really start moving
into bonds bonds become much more
attractive because you're getting
essentially a risk-free asset
you're getting paid three percent to
hold that and that's an important number
as well because you know with your
business trying to borrow money that
raises your borrowing costs to a
significantly higher level so watch out
for that three percent number on the
10-year yield right now bond yields
coming down so we're not really headed
there but we'll see we could get there
definitely by the end of the week second
quarter so far has not been kind to
stocks or bonds and and we've seen today
chinese stocks really selling off
european stocks selling off we're seeing
a lot of red and that's all happening
despite a pretty solid earnings season
most companies have beaten their
projected earnings as you know we are in
week two of earnings season in terms of
the big companies and we've seen pretty
solid numbers right now 79 of companies
are reporting above average earnings or
above expected earnings uh so
even though we are getting those solid
numbers from companies still seeing this
continued sell-off and that really seems
to point to worries about this global
growth environment rising inflation
worries about declining growth and lower
than expected growth numbers we had a
note up from pimco
i'm sorry alliance chief economic
advisor muhammad al-arion this morning
saying it's worries about stagflation
that are really spooking investors
stagflation if you're not familiar just
means high inflation that continues to
hold higher and growth that continues to
hold lower and that that discrepancy
where you know you're not seeing a lot
of growth but you're seeing prices
continue to rise higher and higher and
higher so definitely something to keep
your eye on out there in the market we
are going to get what i think will be a
more than uh expected or a more than
typical response from the market from
first quarter gdp on thursday i think
that's the big report to watch and i'm
gonna tell you why we're to get into
that a little later in the live stream
we're also going to talk about these
inflation reports we are getting the
fed's favorite gauge of u.s inflation
this week on friday we also get a report
on the employment cost index so those
are going to tell us a lot about what's
going on in the inflationary environment
i'm going to tell you what to look
through there we also get durable goods
and wholesale inventories those are kind
of you know for the nerds out there but
i think they could have some real market
moving implications this week as well as
well as confidence data consumer
confidence data from both the conference
board and the university of michigan
those are the two big reports that come
out about consumer confidence and
sentiment we get both of those this week
also big reports on housing we get the
federal housing finance agency's price
index as well as the case-shiller price
index both of those for march coming out
this week on tuesday we also get new
home sales report and we get the pending
home sales report on wednesday so again
a lot of a lot of information we're
going to get about the housing market
which is going to tell us a lot about
the overall economy and if consumers are
really just starting to walk away
because of some of these higher prices
all this i think can move the market
because it's going to tell us what
consumers are thinking and whether this
high inflation high rates and high
prices are getting folks to say hey you
know what i'm just going to stay home
so let's talk about it let's get into it
on gdp and why i think that's going to
be the big report on thursday this week
it's typically not well followed it's
not a big market mover when it comes out
because it's looking back at three
months of of data right so we we find
out in april what happened in the first
quarter january february and march
that's usually not a big market mover
because we're in april right right and
we're towards the end of april what
happened january through march not
necessarily all that important i think
this is going to be different because
we've seen imf the world bank oecd all
these big time big name international
organizations say hey you know we think
uh growth is going to slow down moderate
and really decline not declining excuse
me and really decline in terms of the
pace of growth so if that happens gdp is
going to tell us are we on pace now for
those lowered expectations or are things
actually worse than expected conversely
are things better than expected could we
continue to grow at that higher pace
that we did in 2021 that is not the
expectation really of anybody so
more than likely we will see a miss to
the downside and if that happens that
could really start to worry the market
uh this gdp number is going to tell us a
lot about what happened in the first
quarter and why one of the things that i
think is the most interesting thing to
look at is going to be this inventory's
number now
inventories those you don't know is just
essentially companies buying things to
store them put them away stockpile for a
rainy day when you're buying a lot of
things for inventories you're not buying
because your sales are running off and
you have to replace merchandise on the
shelves you're buying so that you can
put things away in storage and hold them
about 70 of q4's gdp was accounted for
by inventory growth essentially uh 70 or
more than two-thirds of that growth came
from inventories and companies buying
stuff to put it away
that was revised higher to 78 so almost
80 percent of q4 gdp growth was from
these inventories and folks just buying
things to stockpile and put them away
what does that number look like in the
first quarter that's i think going to
tell us okay
were these these things that companies
bought because they expected sales to be
higher because they expected to not be
able to keep up with the pace that
people were buying things at did they
buy them did they actually sell them did
they move off the racks or are companies
still just stockpiling trying to catch
up because these covet shutdowns these
supply chain bottlenecks have just kept
coming and coming and coming
were we able to actually see concrete
sales numbers or are we just seeing more
companies stockpile things away because
they're scared of running out that's
going to be a big theme in the first
quarter gdp that i don't know if it's
gotten kind of the attention that it
deserves from a lot of media folks out
there we also saw within that q4 gdp
report personal consumption for goods
and services both revised lower so
that's that's not a great sign for that
sales those sales that we need for gdp
because
the us economy is all about services
it's all about things moving and shaking
70 to 80 of the entire u.s gdp is the
services number and we have seen a lot
more buying of goods and a lot less
buying of services we need to see that
pattern change and for now that you know
we're out of mass mandates in most of
the country we're out of you know
sales or stores saying you can only have
so many people in your store for such
you know where restrictions are are
being lifted covered restrictions mask
mandates all those things are being
lifted are people going back out and are
they buying are they going to the store
are they going to the movies they're
taking their family out things like that
so that's i think a big thing to look
for in the first quarter gdp report
released on thursday now the other big
thing i think we're going to get this
inflation data we're going to get the
pce report personal consumption
expenditures that's what the federal
reserve looks to when they're deciding
okay are we going to raise rates lower
than keep them the same they look at
cute they look at pce and that reports
out on friday we are going to be doing a
special live stream on friday at 11 a.m
unpacking and looking into everything
within pce what the report said what the
numbers were what they mean and what the
how the market responded to that so
check check in with us friday at 11 a.m
we're going to be discussing all of that
as well as the employment cost index
that comes out on friday
there's a big theme right now within
markets which is that economists are
saying hey wages are rising too fast but
wages aren't even keeping up with
overall inflation so we'll find out a
lot of things on friday and i hope
you'll be with me on friday at 11 am as
we unpack that
we also get this week durable goods
wholesale inventories and a number of
these indexes from the federal reserve
in terms of manufacturing and the
overall
economic indexes from the federal
reserve we get the chicago fed national
activity index the dallas fed index on
monday richmond fed index on tuesday the
kansas city manufacturing fed index on
thursday and chicago purchasing managers
index uh as well on thursday so we're
going to get a view of the economy from
multiple different places around the
country and i think that's going to tell
us a lot about where we are in addition
to that first quarter gdp report
so again this upcoming week we're going
to get those numbers on durable goods
and wholesale inventories as well as
that's going to come from march but
we'll also get this q1 gdp number that i
think is going to be a big market mover
provided it doesn't just come in right
at the numbers uh and folks really start
to unpack that so thank you all again
for tuning in and being with us on the
live stream we're talking through what
investors and really anyone who's
concerned and interested in the economy
should be looking out for this week we
get the q1 gdp report on thursday we get
we get a number of different reports on
durable goods wholesale inventories
those are going to be coming out on
tuesday and wednesday and we get those
reports from the federal reserve
throughout the week i think those are
going to be not as impactful for the
market but definitely something to keep
your eye on also this week we get
consumer sentiment indexes from both the
conference board and the university of
michigan those are the two most widely
followed indexes of consumer sentiment
and confidence they're going to tell us
how folks are feeling about these things
you know
how
how excited or how down really are
people on the economy the university of
michigan's index has been around a
decade low
for the past three or four months does
that trend continue the preliminary
report that we got from the university
of michigan at the beginning of the
month showed us that we're seeing an
increase in sentiment for the first time
since december
does that actually get you know
confirmed in terms of this end of the
month report that goes back and checks
in with more folks ticks uh you know
crosses the t's and dots the eyes and
and looks and says okay was this on
point and we'll find out at the on
friday when we get the university of
michigan's report on tuesday
we get the conference boards index of
consumer confidence and that's going to
tell us a lot
that number has been going down we still
haven't recovered from the pandemic
drop-off in the conference board survey
but we are seeing that number a lot
higher than the university of michigan's
number uh
conference board's number has been
picking up steadily since 2009 but then
obviously the pandemic hit and it sunk
and we really have not recovered to
those gains that we saw back in 2019
towards the beginning of 2020 so the
index picked up last month does it
continue economists are expecting for
that number to decline again consumer
sentiment is what motivates buying
buying motivates you know more sales
more sales motivates higher wages and
more hiring all those things we need to
get back to that that virtuous circle
rather than the vicious cycle of the
economy and consumer sentiment i think
is going to tell us a lot about that so
tuesday and friday we get the conference
boards report and the university of
michigan's report
i think those are going to be very
telling we also get some data on the
housing market which is something that
i've been watching very closely over the
past few weeks we're getting the fhfa
the federal housing finance agency's
price index and the case-shiller price
index on tuesday both very followed and
both really dive deep into what's
happening in the housing markets have
prices that have con that have risen
this year at about 10 to 15 percent do
they continue on that ascent most
economists only expected prices to rise
about three to six percent this year so
if prices are still rising at 10 to 15
percent through the year
how does that work if i i think a lot of
economists are going to have to rewrite
their expectations for housing prices
and are more people going to get priced
out as rates have risen now up over five
percent average on a 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage do prices if prices keep rising
at 10 to 15 percent who's going to be
able to afford these houses not a lot of
people so again that's going to be big
we get fhfa in case shiller on tuesday
we also get new home sales report and
the pending home sales report on tuesday
and wednesday that's going to tell us a
lot about where things are going and
where they've been and likely where
things are headed with these new higher
rates again
prices
rates spiked up in march so we'll
finally see some data on how consumers
reacted within the housing market we are
wrapping this thing up thank you so much
for being with us on the live stream
again this week we've got data on q1 gdp
i think that's going to be the big
market moving report that's going to
tell us a lot about the economy this
week we also get durable goods wholesale
inventories and those federal reserve
reports on the economy as well as
consumer data and financial and i'm
sorry housing data
from the um from a number of different
companies case-shiller and fhfa
looking at the markets the nasdaq has
gone positive we are now up 0.25 percent
on the nasdaq the s p 500 down about
half a percent and the dow down about
point two five percent so moving back
into the green uh for stocks the ten
year yield not about two point eight
percent so things starting to improve we
we saw really the sell-off going through
the day and now it seems like we're
picking back up so
where we end the day i think will be
very telling of the overall sentiment of
the market and of the momentum and where
we're headed um and i think we're going
to learn a lot this week about how
resilient investors think the economy is
and how resilient they are are they
willing to step back in into the market
and buy or are they still hanging on the
sidelines and selling doing things like
that so
we will learn a lot on friday i hope
you'll be with us as we do a deep dive
into pce we'll also look back at the
week that was talk about what happened
on markets and how we expect this
inflation data that we get on friday to
influence the federal reserve going
forward and how we expect that to
influence investors going forward in the
market i'm dion rabone thank you all so
much for being with us on this live
stream we're going to do it again 11 a.m
friday we're going to unpack a special
version we're going to unpack pce and
inflation so i hope you'll join us for
that
thank you so much for being with us on
this live stream and i hope to see you
friday at 11 am